[Música]
y hoy vamos a de maquillar estereotipos
y voy a comenzar con un concepto que
todos conocemos si alguna vez hemos
utilizado que es la belleza
si buscan en wikipedia
les dirá que la belleza es una cualidad
de una persona animal o cosa capaz de
generar en quien la contempla un placer
sensorial intelectual o espiritual
bastante subjetivo no
es decir que la belleza va a depender
del ojo de quien pueda apreciarla si es
bello o no
particularmente yo
aprendí que es la belleza de la mano de
mi madre isabel
ella nació en tucumán en un pueblo
llamado batir one a bastante alejado de
toda la contaminación audiovisual que
tenemos hoy en día de las redes y todo
no tenía televisión cuando estaba en
tucumán
me contaba que cuando era chica iba a la
escuela se hacían los mapas a mano
y aprendió a tocar la guitarra de oído
y a sus 15 años la luz de sus ojos
mi abuelo jose francisco
dejo este mundo
y ella con toda la familia se vinieron a
mendoza
y una de las cosas que ella pudo ver
cuando llegó y que le asombró y le
pareció hermoso fue la cordillera de los
andes la montaña
nosotros vamos la montaña del montón
qué lindo sencillo vista atención
el aluvión hermoso y hoy 50 años después
de su llegada a mendoza abre la ventana
de su habitación que da a la montaña
y sigue viendo ese paisaje y le sigue
pareciendo uno de los paisajes más
hermosos que ella ha visto sobre todo
cuando están haga
y así crecí yo así me crié
pudiendo valorar a ver observar las
pequeñas grandes cosas de la vida
diciendo gracias
buen día
me alentaron siempre en la curiosidad
mamá mamá qué significa esto vaya y
búsquelo en su amigo el diccionario me
decía no me decían nunca que significaba
me compraban estos cubitos para armar es
me armaba cositas me regalaban en aquel
momento era algo que se vendía caucho o
plastilina y mi hermana mis muñecos mis
dinosaurios
nunca me pusieron límites para soñar
puede y va a dar y así en esta niñez me
enamoré de la música porque mi mamá es
cantante
canta siempre con el alma con el corazón
y bueno así me di cuenta de que yo
también podría cantar y la música se
hizo parte de mi esencia y empecé a
transitar la vida la adolescencia y
llegué a la vida adulta y me di cuenta
de que
no era nada más un hobby de que era una
parte importante de mi camino
y la música se transformó también en mi
medio de vida fue mi trabajo y fue la
música la que me acercó a conocer otras
dos pasiones
la docencia y el maquillaje
y hoy después de haber transitado
prácticamente 12 años en el mundo del
maquillaje puedo decirles con certeza
que el maquillaje es una herramienta
social cultural cultural y cultural pero
si son una pintura y está el rímel el
pintalabios no
el maquillaje
ha formado parte de la historia de la
humanidad desde siempre desde antaño
ha estado presente en todas las culturas
del mundo
así inmovilizado estatus social ha
formado parte de rituales de ceremonias
ha evolucionado con el hombre con la
historia convirtiéndose hoy
en una de las industrias más lucrativas
del mundo pero cómo se transforma en
algo lucrativo
bueno
generando necesidades necesidades de
cosas que no necesitamos o casualidad
y si hay alguien que compra
compulsivamente es el maquillador cosas
que no necesita salir lado de la brocha
con la barrick la varita de saúco de
harry potter quiero 5
salió esta brocha con brillos diamantes
y perlas por favor quiero 10 pero ella
tiene 100 no importa
la necesito
compramos todo el tiempo cosas y una
estrategia y una herramienta de la
industria para hacernos comprar cosas
que no necesitamos es
establecer estereotipos
hay muchos tipos de estereotipos en el
año 50 uno de los estereotipos de
belleza en el pin-up boca roja delineado
uno de los iconos del pin-up era una
caricatura que era de tipo
marilyn monroe
pero cuál es el tema con los
estereotipos cuando esos estereotipos
se vuelven inalcanzables
cuando no puedo tener los cuadraditos
miren que le pongo onda
tengo un cuadrado t
las medidas son 90 60 90
y cuando se vuelve inalcanzable y te
bombardean todo el tiempo con ese
estereotipo la persona se frustra se
decepciona porque no logra nunca llegar
llegar a esa meta que le ponen
hace un tiempo tuve la posibilidad de
pisar a una chica
y ella me contaba que cuando se quedó
embarazada
por todos los cambios hormonales
empezó a tener algunas patologías en su
piel como fue la aparición de la rosácea
el vitíligo algo muy vigente en muchas
personas hoy
siendo una madre soltera
su única preocupación era crear a su
hija y dejó de preocuparse por cómo se
veía por la belleza
y cuando termine de maquillar la el
espejo y un poco entre sonrisa y emoción
me dice hace 12 años que no me veo linda
12 años que no te ves linda
wow
heavy
una amiga psicóloga mariela me contaba
que con sus pacientes cuando ella
empieza a ver mejoría
si bien obviamente puede hacer una
apreciación de cómo está esa persona
mejorando a nivel interno una de las
primeras cosas que ya no está es la
mejoría externa porque se con la ropa
empezaron a vestirse de otra forma se
cortaron el pelo
porque se empezó a maquillar se compró
un perfume de iván antes muerta que
sencilla desde
y es así que finalmente
la persona empieza a reflejar ese
bienestar interno en el exterior pero
porque se siente bien
maquillaje
viene del germánico antiguo macarra que
significa modelar esculpir
yo hoy actualmente puede maquillar una
novia una quinceañera una madrina y unas
cosas más lindas que veo es cuando se
miran al espejo y sonríen a mí me saca
este año soy bueno que te lo pasado
y se ven hermosas y sonríe pero yo no
hice nada lo único que hice fue
solamente resaltar la belleza que ya
tenía esa persona que ya tenía esa
persona
y así como puedo hacerlo en un
maquillaje social lo puedo hacer cuando
viene un nene me pide crear el hombre
araña y está convencido de que es el
hombre araña se mira al espejo y cree
que es el hombre araña o pongo un poco
de brillo cree que es una transforme una
niña en un hada en una princesa cuando
el actor
para una obra se maquilla y empieza a
hacer rostros caras y se transforma en
personaje
tiene la capacidad del maquillaje
moldear de modelar
en el mundo actual donde la primera
impresión es la que cuenta quienes nos
dedicamos a este mundo del maquillaje
tenemos la capacidad de poder mostrarle
a las personas la belleza que tienen
pero lo más importante es vernos bien
por fuera porque estamos bien por dentro
porque maquillo
maquillo
porque me gusta seguir viendo el mundo
con ojos de niño
con ojos de asombro
porque aún
hoy a pesar de todas estas lluvias de
información me gusta ver la belleza en
todas las personas
porque amo el arte porque estoy
convencido firmemente de que el arte es
lo único que va a salvar al mundo de su
locura
porque voy a seguir maquillando pintando
sonrisas que surjan del corazón para
construir un lugar mejor
les invito a todos y cada uno de ustedes
a que cuando lleguen a su casa
se mira en un espejo
sonrían
y vuelvan a ver el mundo con esa mirada
de niño con esa mirada de asombro para
poder encontrar la belleza en todos
lados
muchas gracias